la presse quotidienne régionale i les
télévisions locales vous présente le
club des territoires un club des
territoires entièrement consacré au tour
de france l'épreuve sportive la plus
populaire chaque année on est des
milliers de français sur les routes à
attendre le passage des coureurs et le
parcours il fait l'objet de beaucoup
d'impatience chez les français chez les
élus on va voir d'ailleurs ce matin les
unes de la presse quotidienne régionale
qui traduisent l'impatience à connaître
ce parcours du tour de france et la
fierté de certaines régions de recevoir
évidemment les coureurs le parcours qui
a été révélé hier d'en parler avec vous
pierre yves piot bonjour vous êtes le
directeur adjoint de ce tour de france
on va en parler également avec pascal
jalabert opéra les journaux régionaux de
l'est de la france parce qu'elle vous
avez été particulièrement bien servi par
un parcours très bien cette année on va
en parler stéphane meunier directeur de
l'information de tv reina parce que ses
fans de est un peu moins bien servis
vous le tour ne passera pas par chez
vous mais la bretagne dresse une terre
de vélo et vous un spécialiste et vous
allez bien sûr nous en parler puis
nouveauté cette année c'est le tour de
france film qui fait son grand retour on
sera dans quelques instants avec audrey
cordon ago championne cycliste bretonne
elle sera avec nous et on le disait ce
tour il est important pour les élus on
sera avec le maire de quillan c'est dans
l'autre c'est la plus petite commune à
accueillir le tour de france l'année
dernière on verra quel bilan il tire
trois mois après qu'elles ont été les
retombées mais d'abord on va regarder le
parcours de ce tour qui a donc enfin été
révélée et les réactions des élus hier
lors de l'annoncé avec gérant bradley
qui étaient sur place
s'élancera du danemark avec trois étapes
dans cette patrie du cyclisme avant de
rejoindre l'hexagone le parcours du tour
de france 2022 a été dévoilée hier avec
notamment le grand retour dans le nord
de la france une première semaine qui
pourrait voir de nouveaux exploits du
champion du monde français julian
alaphilippe première semaine qui
réservent de belles surprises
le chrono des risques de bordures au
danemark
j'ai pas vu le retour en france donc
ça promet
grosse semaine trois semaines de liesse
pour la grande boucle et pour les
communes qui accueilleront cet événement
planétaire à l'image de lacapelle
marival petit village du lot ville
départ de la dernière étape avant les
champs elysées et pour un petit village
de 1380 ça représente un gros travail
mais surtout une grosse promotion pour
notre village pour le l'autre pour le
grand figeac pour tout le territoire un
grand bonheur une grande rêve que je
pensais pas réalisable et puis ça
devient réalité aujourd'hui la nouveauté
de cette année c'est la présentation
commune avec le tour de france féminin
qui s'élancera des champs elysées le
jour où les hommes finiront leur
parcours et là aussi des villes ont fait
le pari de cette nouveauté associer le
nom de sa ville au tour de france c'est
toujours quelque chose d'extrêmement
porter d'abord ça apporte beaucoup de
plaisir à nos habitants puisque c'est
une épreuve à quelques accèdent
gratuitement et très peu d'épreuves de
niveau mondial aujourd'hui 100 gratuites
d'accès et ensuite ça fait la promotion
du territoire grâce aux aux images et
grâce au dynamisme des sceaux trois
semaines pour la grande boucle des
hommes et une semaine pour celle des
femmes qui clôtureront ce mois de
juillet par une arrivée à la super
planche des belles filles sommet des
vosges que les hommes auront eux aussi
gravi auparavant pierre-yves tuyaux vous
qui avez les clés de ce parcours qu'ont
choisi le parcours du tour de france
c'est c'est d'abord des candidatures ce
sont des villes qui sont candidates on
reçoit à peu près 300 candidatures par
an là dedans il ya les conseils
départementaux donc ça fait autant de
villes supplémentaires
donc quand on a des candidatures ont
choisi d'abord le grand départ on sait
qu'on arrive pratiquement tous les ans à
paris et puis après on trace un parcours
en fonction de ce qu'on a vu les années
précédentes pour avoir un parcours
attractif sur le plan sportif voilà ce
sont des candidatures et après il ya un
choix du directeur du tour de france
depuis je l'aide un peu aussi ce sont
des critères sportifs où il ya aussi des
impératifs de répartition géographique
parce qu'on ne sait les communes les
régions attendent évidemment le taux est
ce que vous vous dites attention il faut
que toutes les régions sera servi au
moins d'une année sur l'autre ça aussi
ça qui rentre en compte tout ça est lié
quand vous tracer un parcours du tour de
france ya d'abord les aspects sportifs
mais géographique il ya des figures
imposées on doit pas faire plus de 3500
km il ya deux journées de repos il ya
les alpes et les pyrénées je vais pas
dévoiler un grand secret mais c'est des
points de passage obligé en suisse y est
les massifs intermédiaires qu'on aime
nous aussi parce que c'est des choses un
peu nous elle est pour casser les
habitudes des coureurs on aime bien
aller dans des endroits un peu différent
puis après il ya des candidatures où on
sent que véritablement il ya des
collectivités des élus qui souhaitent
véritablement le tour de france
il ya des élus qui sont très
convaincants très très convaincant et
voilà donc on fait ce qu'on fait ce
tracé avec nos services sportifs c'est
un métier passionnant j'imagine et on va
longuement parlé bien sûr cette année
pascal on le disait en l'est a été
particulièrement bien servis
donc on est très content
avec un effet la lorraine longwy
tomblaine avec la superbe l'ange la
super planche des belles filles alors
ratio il faut pas confondre la planche
sur la super planches risque l'arrivée
se fait sur un chemin qu'on appelle
blanc entre guillemets donc c'est pas du
bitume avec un même un final un
kilomètre et demi avec de très forts
pourcentages sur chemins blancs donc une
étape normalement qui devrait être très
animé c'est en tout cas bien plus tôt en
début de tour dans les alpes donc j'ai
repéré cette arrivée au à
2413 m gr nom est donc là ça peut être
assez spectaculaire on va voir si je
l'en là philippe arrive à être aussi
performant à ces altitudes et puis il y
à l'étape de l'alpe d'huez qui est
tracée sur le modèle de 1986 quand
bernard hinault et greg lemond étaient
arrivés bras dessus bras dessous donc
les lacets de l'alpe d'huez est précédé
de l'interminable croix de fer une belle
étape en perspective on a une belle
étape dans l'est
c'est le jour j voilà
trois arrivés à malte yport aussi je
sais pas si vous l'avez fait exprès non
mais bon ça se trouve comme ça que tu es
de terrain guide notamment voilà c'est
dans les pyrénées à peyragudes où a été
tourné
demain ne meurt jamais de james bond
tout à fait
n'oublions pas mende la montée jalabert
c'est mon homonyme et puis megève aussi
donc trois haïti pour franchir la
première fois mais tout à fait qu'elle
parlait de julian alaphilippe les
coureurs ils ont leur mot à dire dans le
choix de ce parcours où c'est vous qui
décidez et eux ils ont découvert en même
temps que nous hier où ils connaissaient
avant non il le découvre comme vous
alors il se trouve que dans nos services
dans les services qu'on dirige avec
christian prudhomme il ya d'anciens
coureurs cyclistes professionnels qui
sont des permanents d'assaut sous la
houlette de thierry gouvenou ya françois
lemarchand francs de pertes champion du
monde ancien champion du monde ils vont
tracer des étapes et ils sont un peu
garant du parcours alors évidemment ils
prennent contact avec d'anciens
professionnels aussi pour savoir un
petit peu ce qu'on doit tracer mais
c'est nous qui avons le la coordination
générale ddd parcours imaginez si nous
interrogions tous les coureurs et tous
les élus le tour il ferait 8000 km mais
que dire de ce départ de copenhague on
se dit que la france est suffisamment
grand normalement pour accueillir une
telle une telle épreuve pourquoi passer
ces trois jours à l'étranger
écoutez le tour de france ce n'est pas
qu'une épreuve de vélo c'est aussi je
dirais des racines et des ailes c'est
des vues d'hélicoptère et on a beaucoup
de candidatures de l'étranger vous savez
le premier départ du tour de france en
1954 c'est pas une nouveauté c'est ed
amsterdam et copenhague pourquoi parce
que copenhague c'est l'appui la ville la
plus cyclable du monde qui rencontre la
plus grande course cycliste du monde
celle seller c'est leur slogan et vous
savez il y a plus de vélos à copenhague
que d'habitants donc les gens sont à
vélo et c'est normal quand on peut faire
le lien du vélo de monsieur tout le
monde est là et la bicyclette des
champions et bien voilà on s'est
retrouvés on s'est accordé ça devait
être en 2021 c'est en 2022 merci la
bretagne d'avoir accueilli le tour cette
année en 21 et on est ravi de partir de
copenhague et du dan et on va aller on
va aller en bretagne dont quelques uns
mais pour compléter la question de
campagne il a le danemark il ya aussi la
belgique et la suisse qui accueilleront
des étapes c'est important ça aussi
d'aller dans des pays à l'or européen
mais dans des pays étrangers pour la
visite et et du tour à l'international
c'est ça j'avais raison dès lors qu' il
ya un intérêt sportif on pourrait pas
partir du japon par exemple mais c'est
des pays limitrophes la belgique c'est
un grand pays de vélo la suisse nous
demandaient depuis très très longtemps
avec un petit clin d'oeil à lausanne et
aigle le siège de l'union cycliste
internationale mais ça fait rayonner
aussi le tour de france est la france à
l'étranger de partir de des frontières à
côté du de notre beau pays on va aller
en bretagne justement vous en parler
puis arrive toujours retrouver stéphane
vinet bonjour stéphane merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous
cette année pour le tour de france et
c'est une déception dans cette terre de
vélo vous vous y attendiez comme vous
avez qu'arrive le rap est accueilli le
tour l'année dernière
n'ont absolument pas une déception parce
que ce tour de france et vous venez de
le rappeler il est vraiment universelle
c'est la troisième plus grosse
manifestation vaut il doit être partagé
et qui lie à l'étranger c'est une
magnifique vitrine aussi pour ce que ce
sport représente partout dans l'oural or
c'est vrai qu'en bretagne on est très
attentif au tour de france on a été
terrible l'enquêté l'année passée quatre
jours en bretagne avec quatre jours dans
les quatre départements administratifs
de cette région une région qui compte
aux mille licenciés donc autant vous
dire que souvent christian prudhomme
adore rappelé que la bretagne la fille
aînée du cycliste en tout cas c'est un
une région un peuple qui vit au rythme
du vélo c'est du reste le sport le plus
populaire il y a à peu près 1200 course
chaque année alors avec l'aco vide qu'il
y en a eu quand même 500 vous voyez que
même en période de covile les gens
continuaient à sortir parce qu'il y a de
très belles manifestations
on pense au tour de bretagne le tro bro
leon on peut parler aussi à la route
adélie plouay qui avait accueilli les
championnats du monde et puis on parlera
peut-être aussi de ces champions qui
donne aussi envie aux plus jeunes de
pratiquer vraiment un sport d'exception
et on va en parler de cette championnat
notamment championne bretonne qu'on aura
tout à l'heure stéphane que vous devez
évidemment connaître pierre yves piot
vous nous l'avez dit à 300 villes qui
ont candidaté d'abord peut-être
puisqu'on parlait de la bretagne qui
accueille pas le tout alors on a vu hier
évidemment les maires se réjouir
d'accueillir on en parle beaucoup et
c'est dans la presse quotidienne révéler
des marques est ce qu'il ya des maires
qu'il ya des récriminations une fois que
le parcours est connue de gens qui vous
disent mais et moi pourquoi je suis pas
tout à fait là on a on a quelques coups
de fil on a été oubliés on essaie
d'aller dans la région et c'est plus
facile maintenant il ya treize régions
dont on essaie d'aller dans les régions
à peu près tous les trois ou quatre ans
mais ça dépend souvient il ya deux ans
que les gens du nord avait été très
mécontent du parcours du tour qu'il
desservait beaucoup de sud est qui
n'était quasiment pas dans le nord du
talent fait ils sont bien servis cette
année ils sont bien servis cette année
on essaie d'aller dans ces régions
évidemment en fonction des candidatures
le tour il fait 3500 kilomètres on peut
pas faire le tour de la france et le
tour de france peut pas aller partout
néanmoins on essaie de s'accorder
d'aller dans chaque région comme je vous
le disais tous les trois à quatre ans ça
dépend aussi de notre cahier des charges
au tour de france c'est un événement
monsieur le rappelait extrêmement
important en terme de logistique et
parfois on peut partir où on ne peut pas
partir de certaines villes parce qu'il
ya des aménagements urbains parce qu'on
n'a pas les les surfaces nécessaires
donc ça aussi il faut le prendre en
compte oui vous soulignez tout à l'heure
ses vues d'hélicoptère ses paysages
c'est vrai que c'est pendant un mois la
france qui découvre son patrimoine donc
c'est bien aussi de s'ouvrir à
l'étranger moi je crois que ce débat ce
départ au danemark il a rappelé ce qui
s'était passé en allemagne il y a
quelques années une grande ferveur
populaire qui peut aussi porter les
coureurs sur le début du tour parce que
un tout réussi il faut aussi un scénario
il faut que ces crimes un scénario
je vais pas être un peu un peu rabat
joie mais celui de l'an dernier je
trouve qu'il a été intrigué mais écrase
et très vite partage pourquoi les ports
est cher le vainqueur là cette année je
crois que vous avez tracé le parcours
mais pour que ça soit très animé
d'entrée avec les pavés avec la super
planche des belles filles et qu'on n'est
pas un tour contrôlé d'entrée par une
équipe ou un pouvoir qui d'entrée
s'impose au dessus des autres est un
anesthésient tout le monde avec des
états pour laisse échapper les cours en
plus au classement général là on risque
d'avoir du spectacle tous les jours et
de bell tous les jours c'est pas dans la
région et bras mais le contre-la-montre
à rocamadour c'est une très belle idée
ouais dernière étape 1 d'ailleurs je
crois avant dernière étape avant l'étape
des champs-elysées tout à fait sûr vous
nous avez dit à 300 villes qui ont
candidaté comment on fait pour
candidater pour être ville étape du tour
de france c'est très simple c'est un
courrier de candidature qui est envoyé
avec un dossier généralement maintenant
la lettre de candidature et puis après
c'est des élus qui viennent nous voir
qu'ils viennent nous convaincre voilà
comment ça se passe et assez c'est assez
simple et puis après on prend les
discussions alors si ça se fait pas
l'année d'après ça se fait une gare de
st petit peu dans les tiroirs et puis on
les ressort le cas échéant quand on
passe à proximité
et quand c'est toujours justifiées
sportivement on a entendu alors ça ça
fait un peu de bruit l'année dernière
les critiques de sa mère écologistes qui
disait ne pas vouloir accueillir le tour
de france est ce que il ya des communes
où vous voulez passer et les maires vous
dise maintenant on veut pas du tour de
france on sait à la marge des communes
où on veut passer non on passe à peu
près 5 160 à 580 communes traversées sur
l'ensemble du tour en dehors des villes
départ et arrivée ni et nous on va sur
les départs et les arrivées là où on
veut qu'on aille donc c'est les
candidatures si les élus ne veulent pas
ils ne candidate pas on a 300
candidatures on a beaucoup de villes qui
candidatent pour le temps avec un ticket
d'entrée pour pour être communes point
de l'étape exactement on avait travaillé
sur ce sujet en 2020 à nos juristes
avaient un peu a mené une petite enquête
pour public sénat
parce que en 2020 en plus on se
réjouissait d'avoir pu maintenir un tour
ce qu'elle avait juste été décalée en
septembre et donc à l'époque notre
juriste j'attends du président il avait
un peu contacter les maires pour savoir
comment ça se passait parce que c'est
tout l'enjeu pour ces mères d'être soit
une ville de départ soit une ville
d'arrivée avec
un ticket qui est un peu moins cher
quand vous êtes ville de départ que vous
êtes une ville d'arrivée mais donc
l'idée c'est bien d'avoir son nom qui
s'affiche sur le programme d'un des
points bleus ou un des points rouges et
donc pour la commune de lure en saône et
loire en 2020 savent écouter un chèque
toutes taxes comprises m'avait dit le
maire de 96 mille euros versée à
l'organisateur du tour aso à l'arrivée
des frais en plus ça nous avait-il
raconté des frais de logistique des
frais de voirie le maire disait qu'au
total pour sa commune de faire de ces
communes ville départ ça avait coûté 150
mille euros dont 40 % financés par la
région dont déjà on voit que ça touche
deux strates de notre millefeuille de
nos collectivités locales donc les
maires et également les régions qui
peuvent financer un donc la région
bourgogne franche comté avaient donc
financer 40 % est donc troisième région
bien sûr ce sont elles les départements
à l'assemblée des départements qui
communique beaucoup hein parce que 90 %
+ même des routes empruntées par le tour
sont des départementales les routes
départementales
j'aurais pas sûr mais des départements
de france du même 97% pour le tour 2 en
raison de 2000 2021 et dans un
communiqué d'ailleurs l assemblée des
départements de france elle cite un
votre directeur christian prudhomme sans
l'action des départements le tour ne
passerait pas dans les mêmes conditions
donc voilà des départements qui sont
très fiers de participer à l'effort
collectif avec en plus des équipes
techniques de l'assemblée des
départements de france qui sécurise le
parcours du peloton avec 8 véhicules
jaunes fluo nous dit l adf et qui
vérifie à chaque matin le bon le bon
état de la route ou à passer le tour oui
c'est ça c'est aussi l'importance de
l'aide apportée par les collectivités au
tour de france évidemment on parlait les
villes départ et arrivée et ce qui est
très important c'est entre la ville
départ et la ville d'arrivée c'est la
route ces notes stade nous on n'a pas un
stade comme à côté d'ici le parc des
princes note stade nous c'est la voie
publique si les 3500 km il faut qu'ils
soient sécurisés entretenu balisé
protéger et l'adf et les départements
puisque 97 ou 98 % même des routes
empruntées par le tour de france sont
des routes départementales donc ce lien
là et le partenariat qu'on a avec l'adf
qu'on va d'ailleurs renouveler très
prochainement avec le nouveau président
il est extrêmement important on a parlé
ville étape on va aller dans l'une
d'entre elles villes étapes de l'année
dernière mais le ticket d'entrée dont
parlait quentin c'est le même pour
toutes les communes ville d'arrivée aux
villes de départ on ça dépend de la
taille des communes où il ya des
critères c'est le même que vous ayez une
ville une petite ville où une grande
ville c'est le mc 80000 hors taxe pour
une ville dé paris 120 milles pour une
ville une ville arrivée ce à quoi il
faut quand même rajouter quelques frais
vous le mentionnez tout à l'heure des
frais logistiques techniques et des
frais de communication
donc voilà c'est le ticket d'entrée qui
est
valable pour toutes ces villes et on va
aller justement dans l'une des îles
étape de l'année dernière on va aller à
qui on dans l'aude retrouvez le maire
pierre castel bonjour pierre castel
merci beaucoup d'être avec nous on le
disait vous étiez villes étapes l'année
dernière et c'était la première fois que
vous étiez la plus petite commune étape
du tour comment une commune comme la
vôtre a pu accueillir le tour est ce que
ça a pris du temps et financièrement
parlant comment ça s'est passé
nous devons de cette étape au plus vieux
critérium de france parce que nous avons
le plus ancien critérium de france donc
c'est un peu ce qu'a décidé à etsaut de
nous conclut une étable mais nous avions
candidate et cinq ou six ans avant
depuis j'avais abandonné la candidature
parce qu'on ne répondait pas et puis
j'ai eu la surprise au mois d'octobre de
recevoir un coup de téléphone de
monsieur prudhomme vous êtes toujours
ok pour une étape alors vous aurez une
arrivée voilà terminé cette partie un an
de travail pour toutes les équipes et
bien entendu nous avons réussi à
mobiliser une armée jeudi énormément 150
bénévoles là dessus et nous avons réussi
à mobiliser tous les artisans les
commerçants à travers une association de
soutien qui nous a bien aidés
financièrement le compte
parce qu'on parle en retard ce n'est pas
plié aussi la tva donc ça fait cent
quarante quatre mille euros pour une
arrivée et pour compter 5000 euros à peu
près de frais annexes
entre tous voilà tout ça veut dire que
message pour tous les maires c'est pas
parce que vous répondez pas une année
que c'est plié
tout à fait il faut être il faut être
tenace la pugnacité mais mais mais vous
savez 300 candidatures il ya 35 villes
qui sont retenus à peu près tous les ans
donc le il ya 10% donc il faut il faut
être patient quel bilan vous faites
aujourd'hui monsieur le maire pierre
castel quel bilan vous faites du passage
du tour dans votre commune qu'est ce que
ça vous a apporté ce que par exemple il
ya une hausse de la fréquentation de
votre commune après le passage de ce
tour alors ça on ne peut pas trop le
juger au niveau de notre aire de
camping-car c'est sûr qu'ils aient noces
une grande hausse parce que qui en est à
paris sur les radars par contre 10 ans
internationalement nous avions déjà une
petite réputation parce que nous sommes
une petite ville et qui est située au
prix de certains cols qui sont que c'est
leur nombre bayer ou là le conte le tour
n'est pas passé depuis longtemps mais il
va y passer de ses shows donc nous
avions déjà des équipes l'international
que ce soit
lui et sa canada nouvelle zélande qui
venait passer quelques séjours on avait
même des
australiens et des nausées l'andi qui
chaque année pour le tour de france
avant la pandémie
réservé à quillan même que le taux passe
à 30 kilomètres la route ou 40
kilomètres à la ronde y réserver à qui
on pourrait poursuivre dont trois étapes
du tout merci monsieur le maire merci
beaucoup d'avoir été avec nous maire de
quillan dans l'autre vous avez donc
accueilli le tour l'année dernière vous
était la plus petite commune à
accueillir ce tour merci d'avoir été
avec nous pour nous en parler c'est
gagnant alors on a entendu le prix du
ticket d'entrée qui peut paraître élevé
évidemment surtout pour une petite
commune de 3000 habitants est ce que au
final c'est gagnant pour les communes
d'accueillir le tour de france je vais
vous donner quelques chiffres 1 euro
investi généralement c'est à peu près 10
euros de retombées quand on a des
retombées d'abord direct puisque le tour
de france et 4500 personnes permanentes
qui nous suit nous on prend en charge à
peu près mille huit cents personnes et
le ticket d'entrée d'une ville départ et
arrivée
80plus 120 c'est ce qu on réinjecte ou
en frais d'hébergement uniquement nous à
etsaut c'est à dire les coureurs et
l'organisation derrière ça il ya à peu
près 3000 suiveurs des journalistes
notamment ceux qui est une grosse
famille la caravane publicitaire les
sponsors et toute la logistique donc ses
4500 à 5000 personnes qui viennent ces
bergers tous les jours donc vous faites
le compte ça fait beaucoup de retombées
dans l'est dans les villes les
départements évidemment parce qu'on
n'arrive pas à loger à quillan 4500
personnes comme ça donc c'est tout le
département et la région c'est pour ça
que les départements aide les petites
villes et les régions aussi aide
financièrement les petites villes
généralement pour qu'il puisse
accueillir le tour de france mais le
tour de france a cette particularité
d'abord il est gratuit et puis il va à
peu près partout est le meilleur exemple
c'est quand on fait des séminaires chez
esso et qu'on demande à nos équipes quel
est le tour de vos rêves alors il y en a
qui partant des âmes des délires et puis
en un qui nous a dit un jour le tour de
mes rêves c'est le tour qui passe devant
chez moi mais c'est vraiment ça le tour
de france et le tour qui passe devant
les gens on vient à la rencontre des
gens et c'est gratuit mais avec en plus
indéchiffrable palier des des personnels
qui sont tous les jours dans la caravane
etc mais on revoit les chiffres de
nombre de téléspectateurs sur lequel
vous communiquer en 2020 vous avez
revendiqué le chiffre de 42,4 millions
de français qui avaient regardé au moins
une minute la compétition et vous avez
même parlé à l'international de 3,5
milliards de téléspectateurs
on dit hein c'est l'un des événements le
troisième le plus regardée dans le monde
avec une diffusion dans 190 pays et donc
on le voit en regardant pour les villes
qui peuvent afficher comme cela est bien
là leur commune leur monument c'est une
vitrine exceptionnelle des paysages en
plus qui sont extrêmement bien filmé
vous avez des équipes techniques qui
travaillent extrêmement bien faire les
équipes de france télévisions bien sûr
et donc on a vu ou encore cette année un
des exemples de certains sites qui vont
être affichés comme les sites
exceptionnels on parle par exemple de
rocamadour ou de la cité médiévale de
carcassonne
oui alors il ya un effet les sites
célèbres pour qui c'est un coup de
projecteur mais vous savez la planche
des belles filles l'alpe d'huez
les hôtes aux alpes avec l'histoire la
magie avec le tourmalet tous ces lieux
là ne serait pas ce qu'il est sans le
tour de france c'est à dire que le tour
de france à lui tout seul arrive a fait
reconnaître des destinations des villes
des sites qui n'ont pas une réputation
internationale comme eux peuvent l'avoir
carcassonne rocamadour ou megève donc on
est sur un événement exceptionnel au
rayonnement
exceptionnel et un événement populaire
alors c'est pour ça puisque ici on fait
quand même un peu de politique
rappelons que l'an dernier qu'un effet
le maire de lyon le maire de grenoble
avait persiflé voire critique et il n'y
a ni jo tout de suite qui est le
candidat vélia non mais moi je suis
content de ramener mais mes enfants au
tour de france dont même chez les
écologistes ça divise c'est un événement
populaire cette année au rayonnement
international
et puis c'est une belle épreuve sportive
tout à l'heure on voyait eddy merckx qui
félicité mark cavendish maillot vert
rappelons nous que dit mr ses duels avec
luis ocaña anquetil poulidor on a eu
bernard hinault et greg lemond on
parlait tout à l'heure bref on a une
épopée sportive on a des histoires qui
se racontent donc tout est réuni
l'histoire le patrimoine l'aventuré
sportive et puis ces retombées
économiques pour les villes parce qu'un
effet il y a des retombées immédiates
tout de suite et puis sur le long terme
vous avez parlé évidemment des retombées
pierre yves piot question peut-être un
peu naïve les images et évidemment c'est
important pour une combine d'avoir c'est
son image diffusée dans le monde entier
est ce qu'après elles sont offertes aux
communes les images ou pas ils peuvent
prendre quelques sections est pas là et
pas la globalité puisque les droits
appartiennent à france télévisions puis
à lueur au niveau européen mais c'est
ces images là pour des élus elle sera
absolument fort nuageux parler de
retombées directes mais les retombées
indirectes c'est ce que vous disiez sait
et c'est assez important s'est diffusé
dans 190 pays à travers le monde et à
des reportages et des équipes aussi de
chaînes étrangères qui viennent faire
des reportages à carcassonne notamment
je me rappelle avoir des plateaux un
petit peu partout donc pour des élus
pour les citoyens dirait des villes et
des régions c'est vrai est extrêmement
important mais vous allez l'été
zohar dans la montée d'eze dans le port
de balès qui depuis quelques années
c'est un défilé de cette liste qui
réservent sur place ceux qui logent sur
place donc ça se mesure pas
immédiatement mais sur le long terme
c'est économiquement c'est un poids très
lourd et cette année la nouveauté c'est
le grand retour du tour de france
féminin huit étapes 1000 km on va
écouter avant d'en parler avec vous
marion rousse cayla directrice de ce
tour de france féminin elle était hier
au micro durant gravier mais on veut
s'installer vraiment dans la durée c'est
pas un coup de pub un coup de com on
n'est pas là en disant bah ouais le
sport féminin et là encore il faut
prendre facilement ça a été réfléchie et
si maintenant si instable sait qu'on a
les épaules solides pour le faire et
qu'on peut proposer aux fibres
exactement la même force que les hommes
en termes d'organisation ça montre que
les gens ont envie également de regarder
du cyclisme féminin est on
servant très justement cette discipline
dans le coeur des français et du monde
entier un gros retour du tour de france
féminin pour en parler on va retrouver
audrey cordon ragots bonjour merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous est championne
cycliste avec un palmarès fourni un
champion de france du contre la montre
vous avez terminé 8e et meilleure
française lors du premier paris roubaix
féminin s'est il ya quelques jours vous
pourrez pour l'équipe américaine trek
segafredo on imagine que c'est une
grande joie pour vous ce tour de france
féminin et cette présentation commune
avec le tour de france masculin c'est un
beau symbole aussi pour le cyclisme
féminin
oui c'était je pense
pour nous pour les femmes aurait lieu
général pour le sport féminin c'était
très important d'être d'être là avec les
hommes et d'avoir cette présentation
solennelle officiel je pense que ça a
été un grand moment pour toutes les
femmes présentes hier et puis et puis
pour les femmes qui n'étaient pas
présentes mais qui ont très envie de
prendre le départ de ce tour de france
2001 alors c'est un tour de france qui
sera trois fois moins long que le tour
de france masculin il ya huit états puis
jour est ce que vous le regrettez ou est
ce que vous dites c'est quand même un
bon début
non moi je trouve ça très bien je me vis
tu justement pour pas qu'on ait trois
semaines en tout cas aujourd'hui parce
que tout simplement les équipes sont pas
en capacité de gérer trois semaines de
course aujourd'hui il faut savoir que on
est sur des effectifs entre 10 et 13 6
par équipes ce qui est pas caché les
hommes puisqu'ils sont jusqu'à trente
coureurs par équipe donc on ne peut pas
aujourd'hui gérer un grand tour de trois
semaines sachant qu'on a d'autres
courses au calendrier
autour du tour de france et auxquels on
doit participer puisqu'on n'a pas de
remplaçante pour alicia ses autres
courses c'est difficile encore
aujourd'hui audrey cordon ragots d'être
une femme c'est classe tour est ce que
les choses vont mieux
les choses vont beaucoup mieux c'est
vrai que moi ça va faire quasiment vingt
ans que je suis sur le circuit j'ai vu
une progression phénoménale c'est vrai
qu'on peut pas du tout comparé avec
encore 50 ça les conditions dans
lesquelles on exercer notre métier
aujourd'hui
le nom de course qui apparaissent au
calendrier des courses qui sont
mythiques comme le paris roubaix comme
le tour de france l'an prochain sont que
voilà les choses changent ça va dans le
bon sens les sponsors s'intéressent
aussi à nous les médias s'intéressent à
nous et de ce fait le cercle vertueux se
créer on a aussi le public qui arrivent
et qui s'intéresse à ce que font les
femmes sur un vélo enfin des mots avec
vous audrey cordon ragots quelles sont
vos ambitions pour ce tour de france
féminin
on m'a posé la question il ya qu'est-ce
qu'on pourrait me souhaiter pour ce
premier tour de france féminin je pense
que porter le maillot jaune ce serait
juste incroyable gagner une étape encore
plus et voilà je ne prétends pas au
classement général je pense qu'il y à
bien meilleur que moi pour être
complètement honnête mais porter ce
maillot jaune comme à la finit pas pu le
faire ces dernières années c'est quelque
chose qui rentre dans le coeur des
français qui créent aussi une espèce de
dynamique autour autour de la personne
autour de la course et voilà on sait
tous que le français est plutôt chauvin
et porter son maillot ce serait quand
même assez d'entendre et on vous le
souhaite on vous souhaite plein de
bonnes choses on regardera bien
évidemment audrey cordon ragots tour de
france féminin départ le 24 juillet de
la tour eiffel jour de l'arrivée du tour
de france mais ce cas là on vous suivra
bien sûr on vous souhaite plein de
belles choses merci d'avoir été avec nos
stéphane begnins mots avec vous puisque
audrey cordon à gauche c'est une
championne de bretagne
c'est une championne bretonne c'est vrai
que cinq titres de championne de france
vraiment ça naît ça n'est pas rien vous
vous en parliez tout à l'heure oriane et
dans la première intervention je vous
disais que les cours sont très
nombreuses en bretagne il y en a mille
deux cents parents et bien on voit de
plus en plus de femmes sur les routes
bretonnes et ça c'est une très bonne
chose alors maintenant on va croiser les
doigts pour audrey la nature de pontivy
tu on espère évidemment peut-être une ou
plusieurs victoires d'étape de prestige
et puis n'oublions pas que la la
bretagne a donné de très nombreux
champions bernard hinault maison de jean
robic ou encore petit breton la bretagne
est véritablement une terre de vélo
mairie en suivra bien sûr tout ça avec
vous et stéphane venne et merci d'avoir
été avec nous pour ce club spécial tour
de france
vous qui évidemment suivez ces questions
avec grand intérêt cette présentation
commune puis arrive tout autour de
france masculins tour de france féminin
on imagine évidemment le symbole c'est
une volonté de mettre en lumière
vraiment le retour de ce vide amant
évidemment on s'est même pas posé la
question dès lors que nous avions le
souhait fort d'organiser un retour au
tour de france femmes
on voulait le faire le même jour et le
faire d'abord commencer par les femmes
puis par les hommes je veux dire aussi
que audrey le disent elle a peut-être
pas je vais compléter ces propos à chaud
on a regardé pas mal de courses femmes
et le problème qu'on a comme tous les
autres organisateurs c'était la
médiatisation de la course ici on a
présenté hier le tour de france femmes
au palais des congrès devant 3000
personnes devant beaucoup beaucoup de
journalistes s'étaient eux aussi pour
médiatiser est lancé ce tour qui doit
être pérenne parce que les courses
femmes souvent c'est un problème
économique et de médiatisation et le
fait que ce soit médiatisé les sponsors
vont venir et on arrivera à équilibrer
cette course pour qu'elle s'inscrive
dans la durée nous on veut pas investir
sur le tour de france femmes pour trois
ou quatre ans c'est vraiment s'inscrire
dans la durée que ce soit pérenne et un
engagement de france télévisions de
couvrir de la même manière que les
évidemment évidemment avec deux heures
et demie de direct en plein après midi
première étape le 24 juillet dernière
étape le 31 juillet à la super planche
des belles filles chez vous pascal oui a
toujours on va continuer à parler vélo
on va aller du côté d'orléans cette
fois-ci retrouver florent buisson
journalistes à la république du sang
bonjour florent merci beaucoup d'être
avec nous aller nous parler vous aussi
du tour de france du tour bientôt de
retour les enfants
à écouter en tout cas rien de celle à la
volonté la ville d'orléans qui qualifie
l'arrivée potentielle du tour
grall puisque le tour de france déjà
n'est pas passé par orléans depuis 20
ans c'était donc en 2001 et une étape
départ dans une chaleur caniculaire la
difficulté dans cette affaire c'est
qu'orléans paie sa position géographique
en france à la fois très proche de paris
mais trop loin pour accueillir par
exemple la dernière étape du tour la
mine et la municipalité pardonnez moi
reprend tout de même espoir car une
étape de paris nice devrait passer par
orléans en 2022 et l'on sait que c'est
un peu le passage obligé avant de
recevoir le tour de france masculins les
contacts sont nombreux avec
l'organisateur l'organisateur à etsaut
peut-être pourra-t-il en dire plus sur
le plateau et l'objectif est d'obtenir
une étape d'ici la fin du mandat en 2026
la ville a également candidate et pour
le tour de france féminin 2023 réponse
la début 2022
merci juste une petite question c'est
important aussi la couverture de la
presse quotidienne régionale sur ce tour
de france ça on l'a vu ce matin
évidemment beaucoup de une et même les
jours mais les dents sur deux titres qui
attendait de savoir si le tour allait
passer chez eux voilà c'est très
important pour nous c'est un rendez-vous
fondamentale nos lecteurs attendent ils
y regarde sur les sites internet au
kilomètre près où il est passé du couple
dans le journal aux fins et c'est un
rendez vous incontournable
grosse pression populaire
mais vous le dis la pqr est extrêmement
important je rappelle que le tour de
france il a été créé par un journal et
que nous mêmes nous sommes un groupe un
groupe de presse et la pqr est
extrêmement important comme les comme
les chaînes de radio france comme les
france 3 est un ancrage régional qui est
très très important donc tous les
journalistes ce soit la pqr la radio la
télé c'est extrêmement important pour
médiatiser cet événement et je sens
aussi un petit lobbing même même de la
presse de quelques journalistes pour
aller porter les candidates heures pour
être le messager de certains élus
un grand match international il faut un
stade c'est souvent paris marseille et
lyon ont cessé dans les métropoles là
c'est le village de moins de 500
habitants qui ont la chance de voir
passer l'élite de secours populaire est
mondial et florent le message est passé
auprès de biarritz on l'a entendu on va
quitter le vélo quelques instants pour
parler politique du côté d'orléans une
crise politique à la métropole d'orléans
oui on en a connu une soirée agitée à
orléans pour vous téléspectateurs je
rappelle qu'ici la métropole qui compte
22 communes et près de 310 d'habitants
est dirigée par un socialiste mais avec
les voix de la droite orléanaise un
attelage baroque dirons-nous étonnant
bon an mal an depuis juillet 2020 mais
qui vit peut-être ses dernières heures
hier soir le président socialiste donc
christophe chaillou été mis en minorité
sur un sujet important les compétences
transférées à la métropole et les
éventuelles futures hausses d'impôt
qu'elle impliquerait un désaccord de
fond qui masque peut-être une alliance
politique entre deux personnalités le
maire les républicains d'orléans serge
grouard ex lieutenant de françois fillon
est celui de la seconde commune de la
métropole
olivet mathieu chez singer alors lui
aussi est de droite mais plus proche de
la majorité gouvernementale et il
siégeait depuis 2020 avec son groupe
dans la dans l'opposition à la métropole
c'est un peu compliqué à suivre mais
mais on essaye quand même on saura
mercredi qui des deux pourrait remplacer
le président actuel s'il venait à
démissionner merci beaucoup merci
florent besson d'avoir tenté de nous
expliquer ce qui se passait à la
métropole lorient on vous l'avait bien
fait rassurez-vous merci florent d'avoir
été avec nous a très vite on va regarder
la revue de presse régionale est
évidemment il est question du tour de
france
et comptant beaucoup de journaux de
presse quotidienne régionale reviennent
sur le tour ce matin oui du grand
spectacle dans les alpes titre par
exemple le dauphiné libéré le quotidien
basé à grenoble on parle notamment de
l'étape du 14 juillet noté la dans vos
agendas ou qui s'annonce déjà mythique
c'est celle avec les 21 virages de
l'alpe d'huez journal qui s'interroge
combien de spectateurs au bord des
routes toujours de la fête nationale
quatre cent mille cinq cent mille points
d'interrogation dans l'est républicain
je mal baisées à nancy on se réjouit du
tracé qui passe par la lorraine avec
donc deux jours dans l'ancienne région
le tour revient à tomblaine avec un
troisième passage après les étapes très
remarquée en 2012 et en 2014 jeunes à
leur revient sur la fierté l'honneur
pour les habitants de voir l'événement
passé chez eux dans les pages
intérieures on va même que la ville de
tomblaine avait organisé une petite
réception je passe si vous le voyez en
eau dans dans l'article une réception
pour suivre la présentation du tour sur
un écran à l'intérieur de la mairie et
on va comme ça chaque titre un qui fait
avancer et qui parle de l'étape qui le
concerne lorraine et franche-comté l'est
républicain puisque c'est aussi la
planche des belles filles n'oublions pas
les francs comtois le progrès pascal
fait sa une sur l'hommage à sa mère
pattie voilà après la mort de samuel
pâtit on va voir la une de votre journal
à un choc indélébile l'assassinât du
professeur d'histoire géographie et le
16 octobre il va constituer un choc ce
courant l'éducation nationale et le pays
tout entier dit le journal basé à lyon
en rappelant que la famille ne simule
pas tirs reçus à l'elysée aujourd'hui
note plus joyeuse la touche de content
de vendredi oui il est sorti un petit
sourire est sûre elle est visitée est la
tour eiffel c'est ce qu'on a lu dans le
courrier de l'ouest alors c'est pas
celle que vous imaginez rien de regarder
c'est elle et elle est comme cela elle
fait 17 métaux elle et elle est complet
elle elle est faite dans l'assemblage de
7500 fer à cheval soudés et 7e tour
eiffel bis un peu moins impressionnante
que la vraie et j'allais vendre dix
mille euros ryan
donc on l'a dit le départ du tour de
france féminin merci beaucoup merci
merci à vous d'avoir été avec nous ce
matin pour nous parler de ce parcours le
tour de france merci parce qu'elle sait
mère du groupe ebra et on a parlé
évidemment de l'importance de la
couverture de la presse quotidienne
régionale ce fut au tour de france merci
contente on se retrouve lundi et on vous
souhaite un très bon et m
la presse quotidienne régionale et les
télévisions locales vous ont présenté le
club des territoires
[Musique]